Wir können uns menschen so bauen wie wir wollen jedenfalls sind wir kurz davor die als weggehen schere dafür und superstar der
biotechnologie heißt chris backus neuen technologie kurz christa die euphorie ist groß
erbkrankheiten und krebs könnten damit geheilt werden und
menschliche embryonen wurden mit christopher bereits verändert und genau das macht vielen angst euer dem vorschlag über whatsapp hier die aktuelle
situation bei pixum science fiction herzlich willkommen und vielen dank für den themenvorschlag
Hierzu whatsapp kommt und dort team vorschläge machen können das erfahrt ihr am ende des videos
fangen wir mit den erfolgsmeldungen und positiven seiten von küster klas dem neuen allzweckwerkzeug der
gentechnik an kurz noch einmal zur erklärung mit dieser methode lassen sich ausgewählte gene einfügen
ausschalten oder auch umschreiben und zwar sehr einfach es funktioniert ganz simpel wie eine schere es im august
2017 kamen dann das unglaubliche heraus wir menschen sind in der lage gezielt
in die evolution einzugreifen kaputte gehen raus aus dem körper gesunde gene rein und schon ist die erbkrankheit
besiegt oder viel schlimmer wir bauen uns den super menschen mit einer einfachen und effektiven
technik unvorstellbar doch genau das ist jetzt einem us
wissenschaftsteam an menschlichen embryonen gelungen das forschungsteam aus portland befruchtete in ihrem versuch gesunde eizellen mit spermien
eines spenders der an einer herzmuskelschwäche litt sie spritzten nicht nur die spermien sondern eben auch
entsprechende kaspar proteine in die eizelle diese sollten den kaputten ausschnitt der die erbkrankheit
auslöst ausschneiden und durch einen gesunden abschnitt ersetzen und tatsächlich in 42 von
58 millionen war der gen defekt behoben war doch nicht zu 100 prozent
denn dieser versuch hat genau wie vergleichbare experimente
deutliche schwächen und die sind nicht ohne konkret war bei dem experiment etwas seltsames passiert nicht der
künstliche dna schnipsel der kürzere proteine wo die in die embryos eingebaut sondern der gesunde schnitzel aus der natürlichen
eizelle der eigentlich als kopiervorlage zur reparatur diete zugespitzt formuliert die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler wissen nicht was sie da getan haben ähnliche versuche
mussten frühzeitig abgebrochen werden es gab viel zu viele ungeplanten genveränderung die
ungeahnte konsequenzen mit sich bringen könnten den tod der embryos
fehlbildung krebs oder andere erkrankungen das ist das riesige problem von christa zu viel
geht im wahrsten sinne des wortes daneben zu viel wird auch an anderen stellen des erbgutes verändert und das zum teil ziemlich
unkontrolliert trotzdem zeigt der versuch des us forschungsteams das
gentechnisch modifizierte kinder keine zukunftsmusik mehr sind sondern wahrscheinlich nur noch eine frage der zeit
weitere große hoffnungen setzt das forschungsteam in die behandlung anderer bislang unheilbare krankheiten um beispielsweise mit hilfe einer gentherapie
überzählige chromosomen gezielt zu entfernen und das ist wirklich was eigentlich super positives in einem japanischen
experiment wurde jetzt gezeigt dass das kein werkzeug tatsächlich auch anders kann statt die gewohnte feinarbeit gab es ein regelrechtes
gemetzel und ja es grenzt schon an eine sensation denn dem forschungsteam ist es gelungen ein komplettes chromosom im wahrsten sinne des wortes zu
pulverisiert dafür züchteten sie im labor zellen eines menschen mit trisomie 21
auch das down syndrom genannt ihr habt es vielleicht mal im biologieunterricht mitbekommen bei dieser erkrankung liegt das chromosom 21
drei statt zwei mal vor bislang
gibt es keine möglichkeit die erkrankung noch im mutterleib zu behandeln das sagt doch das experiment aus japan macht tatsächlich hoffnung dass dies demnächst
möglich sein könnte vielleicht sogar während der schwangerschaft auch andere krankheiten wie beispielsweise
das kleinfelder syndrom bei dem ein zusätzliches x-chromosom vorliegt oder das sogenannte xy
incident syndrom könnten so behandelt werden dieses ergebnis ist tatsächlich ein hammer und vielleicht sogar
der anfang eines neuen zeitalters tor
realistisch gesehen ist diese methodik noch nicht wirklich bereit für die praxis denn es gibt viel zu viele schnitte an stellen die so ganz und
gar nicht gewollt sind nicht vorstellbar was passieren würde wenn in einem lebenden organismus
die falschen chromosomen zerstört würden zudem ist die effizienz mit einer erfolgsquote von 40 prozent bisher zu gering ein weiterer
forschungsbereich in dem die christa klaß technologie eine große rolle spielt ist die organtransplantation
auch über dieses forschungsergebnis hatten bei klicks um science-fiction berichtet einem internationalen forschungsteam war es im letzten sommer gelungen eine hürde für die
transplantation von schweine organen in menschen zu eliminieren der mensch wird mit solchen organ zur chimäre mischwesen
aus zwei organismen ein großer erfolg denn
forschungsteams weltweit forschen daran dass auch tierorganen
menschen helfen könnten die nur noch durch eine organspende die chance haben weiter zu leben auch schweine
kämen als organspender für uns menschen in betracht sie sind ja
und sehr sehr ähnlich doch ende der 90er jahre wurden viren im genom der schweine identifiziert die wohl gefährlich für den menschen sein könnten diese
portionen endogenen retroviren kurzpass so heißen diese viren könnten dort immundefekte und krebs verursachen einem
internationalen wissenschafts team ist nun das gelungen woran viele andere
vor ihnen gescheitert waren natürlich mit der chris methode sie hatten rund 30 ferkel erschaffen die frei von diesen
retroviren waren jetzt plant das forschungsteam den per freien schweinestall weiterzuentwickeln
und damit dann sicher und wirksam dass schweine herz in einen menschen zu verpflanzen der fachbegriff dafür
xenotransplantation
noch gibt es zahlreiche schwierigkeiten zu überwinden
bislang konnten primaten nicht lange überleben
denen gentechniker schweine organe eingesetzt hatten alle der sehr wenigen versuche schweineherzen den menschen zu transportieren sind
ausnahmslos gescheitert denn das menschliche immunsystem bekämpft fremdes gewebe selbst das von anderen menschen
das studienergebnis klingt sicher erst einmal
spannend doch viele fragen bleiben noch hoffen abzuwarten bleibt beispielsweise wie lange die gezüchteten ferkel ohne die retroviren im genom überleben werden
bis jetzt weiß man nämlich noch nicht sicher ob sie diese zu überleben brauchen aber was ist wenn sie weiterleben und dann noch einen weg
gefunden wird die schweineherzen gentechnisch zu verändern zu diesen ganzen fragen kommt ein weiterer aspekt hinzu
der moralische sind schweine als ersatzteillager für menschen vertretbar und wo führt uns das alle sind
viele viele fragen und noch viel zu wenige antworten denn das problem ist dass die meisten menschen
außerhalb der wissenschaftswelt zu wenig über diese technik wissen um ihr potenzial ihre chancen und vor allem auch ihre risiken abzuwägen
der ethikrat plan zwar eine stellungnahme zu den eingriffen mit der gen scheren in die keimbahn doch muss es vielmehr den
zu diesem thema ähnlich wie zum klimawandel oder der atomenergie geben wir müssen dringend
reflektieren welches risiko sie eingehen wollen und dabei auch an die nachfolgenden generationen
denken und hier ist die politik gefragt denn im medizinischen bereich herrscht bezüglich der gen schere eine art goldgräberstimmung
die abheben lässt zudem fließen milliarden vom forschungs- und
investitionsgelder nein die die euphorie noch größer werden lassen allerhöchste zeit also für die gründung einer offiziellen institutionen
die das ganze überwacht und regulieren kann und jetzt der aber
keine werbung mehr auf klicks wir haben ja schon angefangen immer mehr videos sind werbefrei dank eurer hilfe
immer wenn wir entsprechend viele kanal mitglieder gewonnen haben schalten wir die werbung vor einem video habt
werdet also mitglied hier unter dem video draufklicken und er bekommt noch exklusiv wir extra videos live streams und noch ein paar weitere
privilegien für einen kleinen beitrag wenn er immer garantiert über aktuelle videos informiert werden wollt dann endet mich bei whatsapp
da könnt ihr auch themenvorschläge machen wie diesen hier und ihr bekommt den link zum aktuellen video deutlich
vor allen andern von mir persönlich auf euer handy einfach hier draufklicken und darunter geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken
werden gehen soldaten jetzt realität bis dann
bleibt dran